ready
good evening and welcome to olson's
books and records at courthouse tonight
we are very pleased to have with us mr
steve cole author of ghost wars books on
getty oil and also a book about journeys
throughout southeast asia currently he's
one of the editors of the washington
post and a pulitzer prize-winning author
and we are very very pleased to have him
with us tonight to discuss ghost wars
and the new updated paperback version
welcome mr cole thank you
thank you maria christina and
thank you all for coming out tonight i
better tilt this
we have c-span with us so when it turns
to questions don't say anything you
don't want america to hear
and
i'm actually looking forward to their
question and answer
discussion and i'm not going to
monopolize the time for too long but i
thought i would uh
introduce the paperback a little bit and
give those of you who haven't
uh
spent much time with the book a sense of
where it came from and what it's about
and
some of the themes in it it's
a
product of my own experience as a
correspondent overseas for the post i
was
based in new delhi for three years
between 1989 and 1992 and during that
time i spent a lot of time in
afghanistan
after that
tour
i was assigned to london where i worked
on transnational subjects for three
years
between 1992 and 1995
primarily nuclear proliferation but also
the rise of sunni islamic radicalism
in
the middle east
and
so i was working on
bin laden in those years
along with a lot of other subjects i
think on september 11th i had the same
experience that a lot of south asia
specialists had which was
along with
shock and revulsion a
sense of amazement that this
place afghanistan and those who had
found sanctuary there had come suddenly
crashing into the center of american
affairs because to be a south asia
specialist in the years that i was
working
on that subject was to labor in a fairly
obscure
corner of the world and an obscure field
i think that was true inside the
government as well as for journalists
most of the
glory went to the
russia hands and the china hands and
those who specialized in the
arab-israeli conflict and
my
ambition after september 11th was to try
to write a history that would
locate
the antecedents of the attacks in
afghanistan where
after all they did
arise from
and so my ambition was to write a
narrative history for an american
audience about the roots of september
11th as they were located in afghanistan
as they were located in american
engagements in afghanistan
and to try to draw a thread from
the moment of the soviet invasion
through to the moment of the attacks
and to do that in a comprehensive way
um
so that was
the project and i'll come back a little
bit to some of the broader themes before
we turn to your
questions just to explain the paperback
which
comes out now a year after the
book was originally published
of course the 911 commission
did its work
between the time that i brought the book
out and and
the time that i had to prepare a
paperback edition and so my goal in this
particular edition was to try to
improve the book
by taking advantage of the disclosures
that the 911 commission's investigators
had made
for me this meant primarily taking
advantage of all of the documents that
they put onto the record
uh
particularly about the last couple or
three years before september 11th
so this is not an addition that is
merely added to it doesn't just happen
afterward i actually
wrote through it in a sense and
integrated into the text
new materials from the 911 commission
that work involved not a massive
revision but it did involve significant
adjustments
and additions primarily to the last part
of the book
uh which which covers sorry by what
percent
were you altering the manuscript i would
say
by less than five percent in a in a a uh
a mathematical sense but
what
essentially i was rewarded to discover
that the 9 11 commission
did not
disclose
episodes in this narrative that i
wasn't more or less aware of there
what they
did was to bring forward quite a lot of
detail and nuance and
understanding
that i didn't
have in particular documents
they they made profound new disclosures
that i
didn't
that didn't touch my narrative i think
principally about the 911 attack itself
where it came from
how it originated
and they i think profoundly revised our
understanding of the attackers
and their plot
but as to the narrative of american
foreign policy and intelligence policy
which is my primary focus
here
um
there were
i think subtler
additions that they offered to the
record i tried to incorporate those
because i wanted
the narrative to be as accurate and and
sort of complete as i could as i could
make it so that was my
purpose with the paperback
it's difficult in 10 or 15 minutes to
summarize a narrative of this length and
complexity
and so i'm not really
going to attempt that but
i would like just as a perhaps as a
stimulus to our
discussion that arises from your
questions to draw out a few themes and
threads that i think
are at least as i look back on my own
research
part of what i've enjoyed about going
out and trying to talk about the book is
that it's helped me
think about its themes and and even
analyze my own reporting
to a greater degree than i was able to
do while i was assembling
the history itself
and also i'm interested as i'm sure you
are in what the relationship between
past and present and present is about
and i think there are
some themes among the many in the
history that speak
with particular
force to the to the present and to all
of the unfinished
business that's that surrounds us
i organized this narrative into three
parts because i think the history
organizes itself into three
chapters
the first is the period of the
anti-soviet war in afghanistan from the
time of the invasion to the time of the
soviet withdrawal in 1989.
the second is the period
after the soviets left and as we decided
to withdraw from afghanistan how that
vacuum was created how it was filled by
the taliban
and
what the afghanistan was that osama bin
laden returned to
in the spring of 1996
when he was forced out of sudan and
brought his multinational army
back to afghanistan and then the third
episode is the effort by the united
states to confront bin laden before
september 11th
on on afghan ground
a period in which the cia among
uh in the lead was authorized to return
to afghanistan
this time for the purpose of capturing
or killing bin laden disrupting al qaeda
and its leadership and so the third part
of the narrative is about how that
effort was undertaken and why
it uh
failed to prevent september 11th
um let me just tease out several themes
from those three sort of phases
and particularly those that i think
are still
alive today in some respect
i think one of the most important
aspects of the anti-soviet jihad that
the united states along with the
pakistan army and the saudi government
funded and
supplied was
the way
the politics of that effort was
organized and managed
and the reasons for that
approach
in particular the united states decided
to subcontract the politics of the
anti-soviet war to pakistan
this was i think a self-conscious
decision
that those involved in the program made
they made it because
they believed first that the united
states had really only one overriding
interest in participating in this jihad
in the first place which was to
challenge and
and to defeat the soviet union
to raise the costs of the soviet
invasion of afghanistan and then later
in the 80s when it became possible to
believe in such things to actually
reverse the invasion
and
in the course of pursuing that goal
there was a sense
that it would be a mistake to
concentrate
to divert attention
to the complexities of regional politics
and regional ideology
this was a generation of
cia officers recently scarred by their
experiences in vietnam who essentially
declared no more hearts and minds for us
we're terrible at picking winners and
losers in the developing world as our
recent record shows we have no interest
in attempting such a thing in pakistan
and afghanistan a place that didn't
exactly reward the british for such
efforts and
the pakistanis if they have an interest
in promoting
muslim brotherhood influenced sunni
radical islam as a mechanism for
controlling afghanistan an unruly
neighbor to their west if that's their
interest in the war so be it we have
only one
interest that justifies our involvement
here and that's to challenge the soviet
union and so there was a
deliberate and sustained policy of
standing back
from the afghan-ness of the war as it
were
and a willingness to let the pakistanis
decide
who benefited
as the war went along
and i think it's interesting to reflect
on this and certainly to reflect on it
in context because
i've tried to articulate it just there
as as in the most defensible way because
i think it isn't
on its face
a
bizarre approach
to the anti-soviet period but i think
what becomes interesting is that as the
80s
move along and as it finally becomes
clear that the soviets are really going
to leave
that that gorbachev means what he says
that he is going to with withdraw
and the soviets begin to demonstrate on
the ground that they intend to leave
that this approach of
managing afghanistan through the
pakistan army and through the pakistan
army's agenda is essentially never
re-examined
or if it's re-examined it's debated and
a view prevails that even in the absence
of the soviet
union's 40th army in afghanistan we have
no interests
sufficient to justify the risks and
uncertainties of getting involved
in reconstruction reconstructing
afghanistan
in building centrist politics
in isolating the extremists who had
benefited from the war
and in
trying to reassemble the rubble that the
war had created
physical
and human by the time the united states
decided to withdraw entirely from
afghanistan to end the covert action
program on january 1 1992
and to
withdraw even from humanitarian aid
projects in afghanistan which was
effectively decided by 1993 or 1994
there was a sense in washington that
afghanistan was an intractable problem
one that didn't involve vital american
interests and that again if the pakistan
army wanted to promote
radical islamic clients as a way of
trying to solve this mess
that was
that might be in their interest but it
was no business of ours and so in this
vacuum
that the united states left as it
withdrew
eventually the taliban rose
and i think that's just the third
theme that i would
try to tease out before we turn to your
questions which is
this question of trying to decide who is
your adversary
and why are they your adversaries very
i found it
fascinating to go back on the history of
american foreign policy in the mid 1990s
and discover how few
americans or for that matter europeans
really
understood the taliban as
a serious adversary of the united states
its interests its values
really
to be fair only
the feminists understood the taliban as
a totalitarian movement
just about everybody else involved in
the discussion
wanted to explain them
as
a force for stability as a force that
would moderate
as a movement that was rooted in afghan
social and cultural traditions which was
simply not the case as their rapid
collapse i think demonstrated
and most of all to avoid the fact
that the taliban really were
an instrument of pakistani
policy that really i don't think it's
possible to understand the taliban's
claims on national power in afghanistan
without understanding them as a proxy
force
of the pakistan army and
indirectly of the saudi
government and the pakistanis and the
saudis both the
secular politicians in pakistan and the
army
as well as the saudi government
continually
argued to the united states
look these guys may seem
medieval to you
but
they are rooted in socially conservative
traditions in southern afghanistan and
they will moderate they will become
normal if you just engage with them
they will
grow the saudis in particular
said again and again
we were a little bit like this at the
beginning the beginning of the century
you know a little bit uh
um
immature as a
socially and religiously conservative
movement and
as we modernized well
the edge came off
that's arguable i suppose
uh but uh
what what's interesting about this this
conversation which occurred largely out
of uh public earshot
i think was not so much that these
arguments were ultimately persuasive to
americans involved in them but that
there was no will to think otherwise
that there was no
context
to think otherwise
in the end
i guess what i'm
driving at is that
i think as a as a country we've had a
lot of conversation about the extent to
which and the way in which september
11th was a failure of intelligence or a
failure of tactical covert operations
against bin laden a failure of policing
a failure of government organization
but we've had
quite a lot less conversation about the
extent to which september 11th was a
failure of foreign policy
there's a lot of
that
observation that we could chew on but i
would just finish with
this idea
that i began with myself in this work
which is afghanistan itself
when the cia was authorized
after 1998 to try to
capture or kill bin laden disrupt al
qaeda leadership in
afghanistan all of the iterations of
that effort
were undertaken without ever trying to
confront bin laden in his afghan context
these were what ahmed shah masood's
intelligence aides who were sometimes
involved in the effort called hollywood
operations they were meant to pluck
bin laden out of afghanistan without
ever
choosing sides in the civil war that the
taliban was waging without ever
confronting afghanistan's humanitarian
crisis one of the worst in the world
without ever attempting to visualize a
stable or modernizing afghanistan that
was regarded as an impossible project
instead this was a police action with a
very small number of enemies whose names
could appear on a list and it was hoped
that they could be plucked off of this
failed state's ground without
bothering the failed state
indeed
one of the iterations of instructions
that were given to cia officers involved
in this effort and who were liaising
with the northern alliance before that
phrase that name was familiar to many
americans
involved
providing the northern alliance with
technical equipment and other
support that might help locate bin laden
as he was hiding in afghanistan
and the instructions
said that the officers engaged in this
liaison could take no action that would
fundamentally alter the afghan
battlefield
now you can imagine this
group the northern alliance they were in
an existential war against the taliban
and al qaeda along the fronts north of
kabul
they were dealing with
opponents who were willing to
take their own lives in the course of
battle
and
we were providing the northern alliance
with
modest technical equipment and
if you were delivering that equipment
you were legally obliged to decide
whether or not by providing this or that
you might fundamentally alter the afghan
battlefield you could alter it but not
fundamentally so i guess it's sort of
like the star trek prime directive and
how you
explain a moment like that in american
engagement or
half engagement in afghanistan i think
is
you can only
reach that explanation by going back to
foreign policy and the broad
contextual failure to see
what afghanistan was and why bin laden
thrived there
so thank you for listening and let's
let's have a discussion based on on your
questions
recently we
read in the post that
the uh
the military which receives about 80 of
the intelligence budget
has been used
to uh to gather intelligence uh more so
than the cia
so what i'm wondering is back then
when we were
involved so much with afghanistan
was there a conflict between the
the military's gathering of intelligence
and the cia and did the military have
any influence on our foreign policy
well they did have influence the
everyone here is some version of the
question the question was referring to
the recent stories in the paper about
the pentagon's efforts to
ramp up its
particularly its
human intelligence
apparatus and its collection
that and the question was in those days
back in the late 90s was there a
conflict between
the cia and the pentagon
over operations in afghanistan
and did the pentagon have a role in
america in the foreign policy and the
answer is that i think
in those days in that period between
1998 and 2001
it was really only the cia that was
active in afghanistan the pentagon
wanted nothing to do with the problem of
a ground
or other attack in afghanistan against
bin laden and repeated efforts to try to
draw special operations command into the
effort
were met
with
a lack of enthusiasm certainly at the
senior levels i think down at the sort
of mid levels there was
an appetite to participate but
none of the leadership of either the
civilian or uniformed side of the
pentagon
believed that there was a plausible path
to
attacking bin laden or al-qaeda
leadership in afghanistan before
september 11th
and so
they were actually quite i think content
to let
the cia take the lead in those days
it's interesting if you try to discover
the origins of this
apparent reported
push by
secretary rumsfeld for an independent
intelligence capability at the pentagon
i think you really have to go back to
the fall of 2001
when it was the ability of the cia's
counterterrorist center
to
offer a plausible plan of action in the
immediate aftermath of the attacks that
it had the relationships in northern
afghanistan with the northern alliance
it had
the history and
a
it had been operating
however
sporadically in the region and so they
were able to put their people on the
ground in afghanistan before the before
the pentagon could get organized and
that really
annoyed rumsfeld i think uh bart's piece
even quoted a memo essentially a sort of
in a fountain head memo that
in which runsfield said why
the is it only the cia that is on the
ground here
a month or six weeks after the attacks
and he wanted to be in a position to put
either uniformed or other
pentagon folks
in the lead at a moment like
that said uh in the mid 90s the
discussion was left largely out of the
public gear shot and as a journalist can
you comment
on uh
possibly a failure in the american press
to
address some of these topics for example
how many other american foreign
correspondents
were in south asia when you were there
yeah i think the media failed i think we
all failed i feel
no
pride about that record there are as
some
corners of the government can
point to there are
pockets of
things you could be proud of there
certainly was good journalism about
afghanistan and its collapse about the
humanitarian crisis about the nature of
the taliban about the nature of the
repression in afghanistan and
both the
post and the new york times i think did
work that really holds up in retrospect
about al qaeda and bin laden i think we
did less well
uh you know that the times had a
pretty prescient package of stories at
one point early in 2001 but the kind of
sustained coverage of what al qaeda had
become what kind of sanctuary it enjoyed
what kind of organization it was how its
leadership worked what its ambitions
were and particularly to focus
on
the most distinctive act aspect
of al qaeda and
bin laden's
leadership of al-qaeda which was the
pursuit of mass casualty attacks in the
united states that bin laden really did
mean what he said and that he had the
means to carry it out because you know
bin laden is really quite
different from many other
terrorist leaders of his kind
in the last 30 or 40 years in the sense
that he hasn't spent his
career skulking from safe house to safe
house he has lived more or less in the
open and has spoken and written
repeatedly about his aims and in the
case of
his desire to
take large numbers of civilian
casualties on american soil
he had made that ambition quite plain
[Music]
and had really spoken and written about
it with some nuance
but
i don't think
a
sustained viewing of american television
network news
or even really a
sustained reading of even the best
american newspapers would have
provided an adequate
account of his ambitions
somebody else has a question
yes i was curious if you would
comment on i think pakistan and its
with with the taliban and how likely
pakistan's policy will change in the
future um
when and if mu sharif either steps down
or is killed
we've seen a lot of conflicting things
between their initial relationship to
more recently taking a strong line and
it's unclear which forces in pakistan uh
seem to be more dominant which how do
you think what the future will
say towards that
well it's a good question i think that
it's a in some respects it's an
important mystery that um is alive in
the american partnership with pakistan
you know i would say
in the three years and
however many months since september 11th
that pakistan clearly has changed its
approach to afghanistan
and
i
was
skeptical for reasons that i'll explain
about how full that commitment
was and still think that there
are questions to be asked and monitored
there but
to me a an important turning point was
the presidential election last last
autumn
when the taliban
failed to make
an impact they really didn't show up and
they had threatened to disrupt the
elections violently and they had
suggested through violence through the
spring and summer that they might have
the potential to really
take a lot of afghan line lives
ordinary afghan standing in line to to
vote in this election
and i think that there was a question
about whether pakistan
wanted to continue to use the taliban as
a source of pressure on
karzai the united states and his ethnic
tajik and uzbek allies as a kind of
whole car not fully disrupt afghan
politics but make plain the potency of a
revived taliban did was that an
intention i think that the pakistan
government and army did demonstrate in
2004 that they'd really broken with that
policy at least for now
and i think that that was a real
breakthrough for afghanistan and
an important reason why the election
succeeded and they did succeed i think
there is still a way
in a very complicated way that
pakistan is holding the idea of the
taliban and the idea of cross-border
jihad in reserve
as a potential instrument of the sort
that they had used for 20 years
previously
in reserve against what against the day
when they fear as in the past the united
states will lose interest in the region
and withdraw and they will be left to
contest with india on their own in an
inferior structural position and for
them the jihadis have always been the
winning weapon against india they're not
an instrument against
the united states for pakistan they're
a way to
challenge their much larger
enemy next door and
when
the pakistanis discovered during the
1990s that a handful of jihadis
relatively speaking could tie down 200
400 500 000 indian troops in kashmir
just by getting them excited and sending
them across the border with enough cash
and guns to wreak havoc
they discovered that really
jihadism was for pakistan's long
unfinished contest with india a
potentially more effective and more
practical strategic weapon than even a
nuclear deterrent and i think that they
there are certainly elements of the
pakistani intelligence establishment
that have not given up on that idea
vis-a-vis india
now they are prepared
for
another way there is this space that
we're in now uh it's the space in which
india and pakistan are trying to
negotiate
a
not i don't think a final settlement any
time in the next couple or three years
but a more sustainable piece
and interregnum
and
pakistan really did prove
in the
in 2004 that they were not going to
openly
support the strategies and tactics of
proxy islamist forces in afghanistan
that they had pursued for so long
just to complete the thought
without getting into too much complexity
part of the trouble is that the pakistan
provinces that border afghanistan the
northwest frontier province and
baluchistan
and not to mention the federally
administered tribal areas where bin
laden is presumed to be hiding these
essentially ungoverned agencies
up on the border
those provinces are now controlled by
islamist religious parties
that were brought to power in elections
supervised by the pakistan army
and i joke with my pakistani friends
that i can't really tell whether the
the success of the religious parties
along the frontier was a mistake or a
strategy and this is something that
pakistanis themselves uh debate uh you
know some people insist that it was not
the result musharraf wanted
skeptics cynics say well it's a useful
form of this
play this kind of reserve against
another day in any event uh it may be
something that he has trouble it's
certainly something that he has trouble
managing today
yeah
uh in the uh the wake
of uh
december
and uh turkey of faisal's
brave and ultimately successful
uh libel award for damages
in uk
against laurel morawic yes
really
formerly uh larushi who was disowned by
the rand corporation and the episode
here but it was a french
publication
express and so on and he donated
his
damages to islamic relief to the people
of afghanistan
uh would you care now that you've been
through your own book twice
to sort of put
uh
the saudi involvement which was
originally sort of a 50 50 dollar
involvement with the u.s
in hindsight for us
um sure i mean prince turkey is uh as
you know he's a sort of a character in
this narrative and so i've tried to
describe
as carefully and fully as i can in the
book what it is that i know but to try
to summarize that
at your invitation
you're right the first part first phase
of partnership between the united states
and saudi arabia was
essentially a check writing
deal uh
in at least as far as the american
partnership with the saudi government
was concerned when the united states
congress under findings
signed by successive presidents
began to allocate
funds for the covert action program
against the soviets in afghanistan
then cia director of central
intelligence bill casey went to saudi
arabia and enlisted the commitment of
then king fod to well i guess it was
first khalid and then fod to write
matching checks for the american
allocation so whenever it was determined
what the congressional allocation would
be the saudis would write a matching
check dollar to dollar and that money
would be pooled
and managed through the pakistan army to
support the jihad and that was the
principal official channel of u.s and
saudi support for the anti-soviet jihad
however the saudis had their own
separate unilateral operations run
through charities run through their own
intelligence service this too involved
more check writing than operating but it
did involve an aspect of their
presence on the frontier that was
outside of the american partnership and
the american channel
presence involved
well it involved building religious
schools it involved supporting
wahhabi charities and involved
eventually working directly with
representatives like osama bin laden to
build military facilities and other
logistical support for saudi clients on
the frontier particularly clients like
jalaladin haqqani who's still
an important
taliban flagged fugitive
in afghanistan and who some people
speculate may be uh one source of uh
osama's current refuge
and when
part of what i try to describe is
exactly what
osama's relationship with saudi
intelligence was in these years and i i
did interview
uh saudi prince turkey's principal chief
of staff in these years ahmed badib and
his
the the head of
the saudi equivalent of the directorate
of intelligence the analytical wing of
the intelligence department who was
ahmed badib's brother and
and
sayed badeb and they
did have
connections with osama in those days
everybody was sort of more or less
swimming in the same direction but
osama's work was in the what i would
characterize as the saudi unilateral
channel that
uh i think one of the more interesting
mysteries and you know i sort of feel
like i have
something of an outline
understanding of
saudi work in the 80s
i think
the saudi government's relationship with
the taliban in the 1990s is a is still
an important mystery in in some respects
there were
similar there was a similar
diversity of channels by which the
saudis engaged with the taliban the
saudi ministry of
the religious police as it's commonly
called the ministry for the prevention
of
vice and the propagation of virtue
um you know they they had one channel
with the taliban and
and uh then the foreign ministry and
prince turkey had other channels and so
forth there's a lot about that period
that we don't that we don't know
you said that if i heard you correctly
you thought that the past
was relevant
to the present
and i hear that as well there are
lessons to be learned here and applied
now
are the foreign policy establishment
here
learning those lessons and applying them
well i think
some of them
uh
as to afghanistan
uh certainly the
american commitment to reconstruction
stability and centrist politics is
pretty thorough going whether it's
sustainable or not or not i think is a
question
about which it's
difficult to be confident
i think that the areas where the lessons
feel
less fully baked
involve the alliances with pakistan and
saudi arabia in particular
even if you take the most hard-headed
frame for evaluating
american partnership with the pakistan
army you have to observe that
while we have come very close together
since september 11th
both in terms of
operating against al-qaeda leaders in
pakistan and along the border in
partnership on the reconstruction of
afghanistan
and
through the provision of multi-billion
dollars worth of military hardware and
aid to the pakistan army
that
this
partnership is still involves two
governments with very different
interests
in the partnership and
i think that there's one of the i would
be interested in other people's uh
reactions to this but one of my own
reactions to the full narrative of the
liaison between the united states and
pakistan particularly the collaboration
between the cia and isi
but it speaks to the larger relationship
as well is that
inevitably and any of you have worked in
government or in bureaucracy know how
this happens there's a certain momentum
of liaison that builds up so that the
liaison just
exists to justify itself and it becomes
very difficult to break out of the
assumptions of the partnership however
poisonous they may at a certain stage
become and find the
eyesight the vision and the courage to
act
in your own interests and
i think the pakistanis
because they feel they have a lot on the
line the existence of their nation state
have tended to be a little more ruthless
in that respect
and
whether or not
the public celebration of the
unblemished unmitigatedly successful
partnership that is now allegedly
enjoyed between the government united
states and the government of pakistan is
privately seen with
a more realistic set of eyes is
difficult for me to be confident about i
presume that all of the public
celebration that the
partnership is
couldn't be better there's i think we
post had an interview with the president
recently in which
we were asking about why he thought
osama bin laden hadn't been captured and
his first line was because he's hiding
and then
the second
follow-up question was something the
effect of well do you think
your partners are as fully engaged in
this as they should be
and he said i can't think of a single
alliance uh involved in this hunt where
where there's a single flaw in the
alliance our partners are absolutely
great and you know now that's the sort
of thing you might say in order to keep
a shaky partnership organized
but i presume it's not actually what
anybody
believes what's what's more interesting
is the complicated question of how the
divergent interest of the pakistan army
and the united states and the hunt for
bin laden can be successfully managed
because the pakistan army's concern
in the search for bin laden
is not that his capture will bring the
house tumbling down or that they can't
stand the political heat or other things
that are occasionally speculated about
in my view and my sense of things from
talking to those involved on the
pakistani side
their concern and it's quite reasonable
if you sit in their shoes is that as
soon as bin laden and safari are in
custody the united states is going to go
home and or tilt to india quite
dramatically and that basically this is
the pattern of american partnership that
as soon as the americans have what they
came to south asia for
they either go home or they turn and
support our enemies and really from a
pakistani point of view this is not an
unreasonable reading of history in 1971
uh you know we let the country be
dismembered uh after the anti-soviet war
we walked away
uh we in fact we didn't just walk away
we slapped pressler on in addition and
mothballed their f-16s so if you're
sitting in their shoes and you and
you're asking what's going to happen
when bin laden is wearing striped you
know prison suits and and there's nobody
left on the frontier to worry about
and especially with all of the momentum
and the natural strategic partnership
between the united states and india
that's building up which is sort of
undeniable
well you know how do you manage that
insecurity in the relationship without
creating an environment in which somehow
the pakistan army does not do 150
percent of what it's possible to do to
actually bring bin laden and zouahri to
justice because
really musharraf i think after two
assassination attempts
is persuadable on the point that al
qaeda is
is a mortal enemy of the state of
pakistan as well as of the united states
and i'm not suggesting that
they're harboring bin laden but
but
have we really worked out
enough mutual confidence
to ensure that every effort that could
be made will be made
i don't know
pakistan
are run by
individuals have an extremist religious
view
given the present situation in pakistan
what are the trends of these religious
schools are they
less influential
and are there fewer in number
well there have been some notional
educational reforms in pakistan since
september 11th
their their effect on the ground i think
has been so far around
the margins
i think the religious schools the
madrasas are important but
i'm not sure that they are as central
uh
to the problem of mass casualty jihadism
as sometimes our
discussions
make them
if you
carefully
analyze who the most dangerous
jihadis are they are not by and large
products of the madrasas
where which are really sort of
catchments for the disenfranchised in
pakistan
now the taliban
leadership did emerge from diobandi
madrasas and particularly
a dangerous one
east of peshawar but
many of the attackers
that have carried out
the most
violent
assaults on american and western
interests
are
alienated
english medium educated technically
educated
middle
class radicals who
like many other kinds of leftist
radicals and other radicals before them
appear to have been radicalized as part
of their
unfinished
engagement with
western
education western systems
so who today are the most dangerous
jihadis in the movement that al qaeda
now aspires to lead since it's no longer
really an organization the organization
has been smashed but it's left behind a
movement that's very broadly distributed
and
you know i think a lot of the
answer to that question for instance
lies in in europe where you have second
and third generation
young muslim men who
[Music]
have
been
unable to integrate into european
societies that haven't had the success
with
integrating immigrant communities and
establishing a broad pluralism that the
united states for all of its flaws has
had
and
i think also if you look at just the
hamburg cell or the madrid cell or
you know pick a cell basically and you
analyze the educational roots of the
most violent radicals in that group
you end up in technical schools
speaking english not in the in the
madrasas in many in many cases
anybody else somebody else yep
what do you think would be the political
military consequences of mushar being
assassinated tomorrow what do i think
would be the political military
consequences of musharraf being
assassinated tomorrow
i think that they would not be
immediately severe i think that the
core commander group around musharraf at
the top of the pakistan army is
like-minded that it is disciplined
and that it has already thought through
the possibility of musharraf's
disappearance with with good reason
and that the army
leadership
on the whole
believes that
the interests of the army are served by
broad brush are served by the policies
that musharraf has pursued
and i think they're right about that the
interest the army has been well rewarded
on the whole for the policies that
musharraf has pursued
there could well be nuanced differences
in the management of those policies by a
particular successor of musharraf and
the history of army chiefs in pakistan
is one
of occasional wild cards
uh aslam begged for instance in the
early 1990s we now understand to be one
of the root collaborators with iran on
nuclear matters
sometimes these guys come up the chain
and they sort of break out of the
of the policy
consensus that the court commanders have
been operating with or they twist it and
turn it in a new direction so you can't
rule that out but i think essentially
what musharraf represents is a
particularly
fluent
general in western idioms who is
nonetheless representing a consensus
among his
disciplined
senior leadership in the army
i think that actually
the
issue in pakistan in the medium run is
not
the
lack of a consensus among the senior
uniformed generals about
the broad outline of policies now being
pursued but whether or not the army
with creative american and indian
collaboration
will learn to share power and by sharing
power strengthening strengthen the
country and even strengthen itself as an
institution
this is the real trick
and and i don't know how good musharraf
is at that trick
like a lot of despots he's become
enamored of his own position and you can
feel that in the way that he
interacts
with
people
but
at the same time he is looking for a way
to
broaden the political base that the army
operates in he's trying now to draw the
pakistan people's party back in
to politics that would be a good thing
if he could figure out a way to do it
but he doesn't want to actually share
power with the pakistan people party's
leaders so that becomes
a hard objective to achieve and
you know there have been some generals
in pakistan's history that have been
better at domestic politics than others
and i think that more than a consensus
within the core commander group is the
challenge that musharraf now faces he
has to rise to a different kind of
politics and succeed
and i i think that
he has to do that for the army's sake
but also
for for pakistan's
what sake your take on the the new
quasi-democratically elected karzai
government is this
experiment
um
in such an islamic country
feasible is do you see this working in
the long term or
once the united states pulls out
do you see this as being something that
you know was a small chapter in afghan
history and
that's it
how do we think about the karzai
government and its longevity its
dependence on the united states what's
the nature of this experiment
i think that
um
it is
a
not an aberration
entirely in afghan history that it's a
tentative
and uh in many ways hopeful restoration
of an extension of
the centrist afghan politics that were
present in the long period of peace
between
1930 and
1970 and that karzai's
success while inseparable from american
support
now and for the foreseeable future
is not
rooted solely in his partnership with
the united states and the international
community it is also
very profoundly rooted in
afghan politics and the desire after 20
years of shattering war
of
afghans of many stripes to construct a
different
kind of politics in a different nation
and i think that
the
the dog that didn't bark
in afghanistan over the last three years
has
had opportunity to bark a number of
times and has stood down fahim
uh
the
thuggish defense minister and
intelligence chief and partner of ahmed
shah massoud who locked out of the
spoils of the cabinet
accepted
his
fate without trying to organize a coup
d'etat
canooni another
disappointed member of the cabinet
decides to start a political party and
not to point a tank barrel at his
adversaries
dostum
ismail khan
made the poster boy of the warlords who
have to go
he accepts ministry of minds and energy
or whatever it is he's got now you know
good for him uh it's probably a pretty
lucrative ministry as these things go
not to cast aspersions on his integrity
but i mean it's a it's a you know it's
the kind of normalization of politics
that's essential if this is going to
stick and it's happening it's happening
not because
the americans want it to happen it's
happening because afghans are making
this decision time and again
why did the taliban not turn up in
november yes the united states
delivered the security regime
with the resources it had that was
necessary yes so did nato and the united
nations and others collaborated
successfully on the role that outsiders
could play
but the taliban didn't show up because
ordinary pashtuns made it impossible for
them to operate ordinary pashtuns
essentially rejected the taliban as a
vehicle for pashtun aspirations
what's what's the most unfinished
business in this respect
it's pashtun politics
if
afghanistan can organize
over the next five to ten years
with the space that the international
communities and american
policy creates
ordinary pashtun politics that resembles
the decision-making i referred to in the
northern alliance which was a mature
political movement
in a sense
then i really then there's really hope
right now
the big problem
in a sense if you wanted to reduce it
in afghanistan politically is that if i
me if hamid karzai were to be run over
by a bus tomorrow
there is no committee of pashtun
political leaders who would meet to
choose his credible successor and whose
decision would be regarded as credible
among the broad range of pashtun
constituents
that's the moment afghanistan has to
arrive at that there that
that this is not all about hamid karzai
anymore that it is about parties
political parties that represent diverse
pashtun points of view
that are engaged in constitutional
politics and the parliamentary elections
are very important in that respect
because they will produce the basis for
such politics but then it has to be
actually created and it'll take
some time
um
but anyway i feel overall uh optimistic
it's getting colder and colder in here
the woman with the glove
speaks to me
for extending the fragile
optimism that you have in afghanistan to
the iraqi election
yeah is there is there a basis for
similar optimism in iraq not not visible
i think that the the most interesting
i mean obviously you all understand as
well as i do uh what's happening in iraq
because i haven't walked around that
insurgency
and you know i've been there
once uh and and really don't have a rich
confidence about
the insurgency
but i
i do
have a couple of thoughts one is that i
think the
if you ask the question as i sometimes
try to do what's happening in iraq
that matters that we understand the
least
and in the region in a way as a result
of
what's happening in iraq and i think it
one answer to that is the shia revival
there is a very powerful
moment
in
shia communities
in the arab world and globally that
is
at the heart of what's going to unfold
this week in iraq
the other side of the
coin
on the other side of the sunnis
insurgency bathurst nationalist
insurgency
is
a community's commitment to this
constitutional process yes out of
self-interest but also as part of a
broader regional revival a moment of
enfranchisement for a community that has
felt profoundly disenfranchised not only
in iraq but elsewhere in the gulf i was
talking to somebody who was in saudi
um talking to folks about the these
municipal elections that are due in a
couple of weeks that are you know they
don't amount to a whole lot but they're
something to measure and they're
interesting
and
he was out in riyadh
asking who's registering to vote
and
in riyadh the answer was not very many
people so far
but apparently in the eastern
areas around dahran where the shias are
prominent registration is running at
very very high rates
you know why well because there's an
echo from
what's happening in iraq and
uh
so i i think that
if you try to look at these elections
from an iraqi
rather than an american point of view
those are some of the things you might
observe where it leads
involves more than we want to talk about
tonight but
um
but the violence and the breadth
and
complexity of the
sunni-based insurgency
has no analog in afghanistan mercifully
and doesn't look easily addressed by
these elections
i'm
generally working in the same territory
as this last one but i'm i'm going to
work a little more on on saudi arabia
this next time around it's going to be a
long time before you see the fruits of
that work
that's about as much as i'm prepared to
say thank you though for your interest
yes
of our relationship with the northern
alliance from september 10th
to september 12th
especially considering how much trust we
placed in them
in the war on terrorism in those
following months i mean there's it's
been reported that there were
bounties paid to them for prisoners that
they turned over to us who may or may
not have ended up in guantanamo bay and
i was wondering how strong that
relationship was before
september 11th well i think
part of what i tried to document and
narrate was
that
on september 10th there was an
unresolved and unfinished well it was
resolved but not in the favor of those
on the northern alliance side of the
argument there was an argument about
whether or not the northern alliance
should be seen as an ally of the united
states or not
and
particularly
at the cia in the two years before
september 11th a forceful case was made
from the working level not always made
at the leadership level
that we really ought to choose sides in
this afghan war and that was the only
serious way to confront bin laden and
the only way to choose sides was to
choose sides with the northern alliance
whatever their
flaws whatever their limitations that
this was an urgent matter it required us
to choose sides and these were our
natural allies now they had made that
case a number of times and in the end
they were unsuccessful in persuading
either the
cabinet of the clinton administration or
the
cabinet of the bush administration the
first nine months of 2001 to go all in
but because they had been making this
case and
trying to develop it in some detail
which involved proposing specific forms
of collaboration with the northern
alliance on september 12th it was very
easy to leap to the all right well now
let's try this
and it wasn't happening in a vacuum i
mean there were very specific
options that had been developed about
how you would collaborate militarily
with the northern alliance and it was
that plan that put
the agency in the lead in the first
weeks of september of september 2001 and
was that that was why
rumsfeld to go back to an earlier
question felt left out because
when the agency marched into the oval
office in those urgent
hours uh and days after september 11th
they had something to say
here's a specific plan this is a plan
we've drawn up it's based on experience
we've been on the ground with these guys
we know what they need to operate we
know who they are here's who they are
here's what we want to do and the
pentagon because it had held back from
engagement with afghanistan and argued
against engagement with afghanistan
wasn't
didn't have a comparable
program so that was the reason that it
happened so rapidly was because it
essentially
was already drawn up
uh when september 11th happened
how did you become interested in the
region was it your curiosity did an
editor nudge you was there something
else
uh it was
an accident really
of my professional life i
joined the post as a reporter in 1985
and
as i
came to have a newspaper career i
thought very quickly that i wanted to be
a foreign correspondent the way it works
at the post is it's a very
you know it's like a lot of other places
very competitive to try to get a foreign
correspondence job and so when you want
to apply
you have to essentially declare that
you're willing to go anywhere so that's
what i did i said that i was willing to
go anywhere anytime you know
and
so in the course of uh being appointed
to that staff
i thought i was going lots of different
places and in fact
not to tell a boring story about myself
but it was kind of a moment when i was
still am married had young kids and
my wife was very adventurous wanted was
willing to apply basically a blank sheet
of paper but
we had been told we've been led to
believe in the course of this
application process that we were going
first we were going to south africa then
we were going to poland and i was called
down to a meeting in washington we were
living in new york
right on the cusp of our making our
final commitments and i go into a
meeting with my boss and he starts
talking to me about okay you're gonna
this is how the moving works and these
are the logistics and so forth and about
20 minutes into the conversation i
realized that he was assuming that i was
going to india which had never been
mentioned by anyone at any stage along
the way
and i i didn't want to seem like
reluctant uh to go or or sort of like i
had any second thoughts about going to
because they seemed to have already made
the appointment
but i asked if i could just like take 10
minutes just have a break and i went out
and i called home and said
how do you feel about going to india and
that was it was okay so that's how i i
went and when i was there
afghanistan was
a a big part of what the washington post
was interested in that part of the world
and i became very interested in it as i
traveled in afghanistan and discovered
it from um through my own experience i
just became more and more involved in
the region and you know i have to say
we were just back in india for christmas
and i think south asia is just one of
those places that for some people it
just kind of takes hold of you and never
really lets go and i've now
worked just about everywhere in one way
or another and
this is still the place that i feel
the most involved in as you can
undoubtedly tell
me on how
america's relationship with israel has
provided popular support for the
jihadists around the world how has
america's relationship with israel
provided popular support for jihadism
around the world
well i mean obviously the unresolved
conflict between
israelis and palestinians
is an essential part of
the context in which
a substantial
part of
radical of islamic radicalization occurs
and so i don't think you can
sort of say oh well
it's a sidebar it's context
what's interesting about bin laden i
think
though
is that he has never really been very
seriously interested in the
israeli-palestinian conflict
even rhetorically he came to it quite
late
and his own
engagement with it
was
you know was almost like a speechwriter
started to put it into his remarks after
a certain point he did have one personal
connection uh in his relationship with
abdullah azam during the 1980s abdullah
zam palestinian muslim brother who was
the founder of a precursor organization
of al qaeda and so it's not as if he
wasn't acquainted with the issues and he
did advocate for american boycotts and
anti-israeli boycotts in the 1980s as
part of his speech making so i mean to
be fair to him you know he he did speak
about the issue but as he independently
even early but as he independently built
up al qaeda after azam's assassination
in 1989 and as he defined
al-qaeda's global campaign he moved
increasingly away from
rhetorical or other concerns involving
the israeli-palestinian conflict it's
notable that
to date
so far as we know
no cells
that we would
strictly call al-qaeda have even
attacked israeli targets
in part because the targets are very
hard
and whenever they've scouted them
they've basically backed off uh zawairi
in his memoir writes about how they
ended up bombing the egyptian embassy in
islamabad in 1995 he sent his team down
first mission was
hit
the americans
they looked at the embassy and said it's
too hard to hit they said okay well then
hit the brits they looked at the embassy
they said it's too hard to hit and they
said okay well then look at the
egyptians and they say well that we can
do and
i think with the israelis that you know
occasionally they've they've kind of
come off of targets but
but bin laden's concerns are saudi i
mean bin laden i think has to be
understood as
a
um
as a sort of
a saudi
global jihadist and
i think that the groups around him the
egyptians
the algerians the yemenis
and others who have made up the chechens
the uzbeks i mean those who have made up
the sort of heart of his
hardcore whether in the sudan phase or
in the afghan phase
have been
by comparison to other arab radical
populations relatively disinterested in
the israeli-palestinian conflict
and also one other thing you know after
all palestinian opera aspirations even
hamas aspirations
have
in some important respects national
aspirations they are seeking
a nation-state and bin laden isn't
interested in nation-states
except in some redrawn 7th century map
sense he's interested in something else
and so all of this complexity of
local politics and and
the bargains that seeking national
status require don't interest him
thank you very much for your attention
i'm signing i guess
thank you very much and we're going to
start the site
steve kaul is a former managing editor
for the washington post and served as
the paper's south asia bureau chief from
1989 to 1992. he won the pulitzer prize
in 1990 for explanatory journalism
ghost wars is published by penguin get
information online at penguin.com